[Music]
thank you
one of the important subplots within
Philip K Dick's novel The Man in the
High Castle concerns the founding of a
new jewelry company called Ed Frank
custom jewelry and there's a lot of
interesting intersections of characters
and their actions and choices and
engagements that are going on with this
that almost result in one of the key
Founders going to prison and then being
killed as a result and the entire thing
begins out of desperation and through
the means of we could call it fairly
minor crime at least it's viewed so by
its victim but then they wind up
producing
something new something original
something
important which we're discussing
elsewhere in terms of these values of
Wabi and woo so we begin at the start in
chapter one with the terrible situation
of Frank Frank he's lying in his room
wondering how to get up he he screwed up
he's fired yesterday he'd done wrong at
the factory spouted the wrong kind of
talk to Mr Wyndham Matson who had a
dished in face with a Socrates type nose
diamond ring gold fly zipper in other
words a power a throne
and he says now they're going to
Blacklist me my skill is no use I have
no trade 15 years experience gone and he
goes through a whole discussion about
what's going to happen and how he can't
really get away from Windham Masson
right he says he'd never been able to
make out when to matson's relationship
to the peanuts the puppet white
government at Sacramento and he couldn't
fathom his ex-employers power to sway
the real authorities the Japanese
if he failed in going before the
laborers justification commission to get
a justification there he would make his
way to one of the Imperial import export
trade missions and which had offices but
if you failed successfully to plead
there he's thinking where would I go
I mean I could go to the Rocky Mountain
States perhaps but they might extra
extradite me what about going to the
American South he says as a white man he
would have plenty of place in fact more
than he had here in the PSA but he
didn't want that kind of place it's an
apartheid sort of community and worse
the South had a cat's cradle of ties
economic ideological and God knew what
with the Reich and Frank Frank was a Jew
so we find out that you know this is
actually a dangerous situation for him
being fired and having to be out of work
so a few chapters later in chapter four
we begin with Frank Frank going to his
place of work watching his ex-employer
waddle down the corridor and into the
main work area of WM Corporation he
thought to himself the strange thing
about Windham mats and he doesn't look
like a man who owns a factory he looks
like a tenderloin bum a wino and he goes
on
but old WM was really very powerful he
owned controlling interests in a variety
of Enterprises speculations real estate
as well as the WM Corporation Factory so
Frank needs to get back in good with him
and what happens well he goes up to him
and we read the old man it's stopped by
the hairy arm shop foreman Ed McCarthy
both of them glanced up as Frank came
towards them moistening his lips
nervously went to Matson said I'm sorry
Frank I can't do anything about taking
you back I've already gone ahead and
hired so I'm going to take your place
thinking you weren't coming back after
what you said
Frank says I came for my tools nothing
else his own voice he was glad to hear
was firm harsh and then he voiced him
off on Ed McCarthy and so
you're not getting his job back and this
is going to be a problematic situation
but then in that same chapter in this
engagement
Ed McCarthy the shop foreman
suggests something quite interesting
he says you came to get your job back
right and then he says I was proud of
what you said yesterday Frank says so
was I but Christ I can't work any it out
anywhere else you know what
um and then McCarthy says well I don't
know that you're good with the flex
cable machine as anyone on the coast so
he's saying you know you're really great
and then he says did you ever think
about going into business
on your own
and Frank says well doing what he says
jewelry
custom original pieces not commercial
he says for about two thousand bucks you
could set up a little basement or garage
shop one time I drew up designs for
women's earrings and pendants you
remember real modern contemporary
and then Frank asked well is there a
market for that sort of thing and
McCarthy says well create a market
he says you sell it yourself you mean
sell it myself we'll take it into retail
shops like that what it's called on
Montgomery start straight that big ritzy
art object place and he taught they're
going back and forth about this and so
what are they actually considering
doing something new something
entrepreneurial taking a risk
beginning to create
artwork that hasn't been done and
they've both got a lot of skill because
the you know work of the Windham or the
WM Corporation is turning out forgeries
right so they're both very good with
working at at stuff and then they have a
very interesting discussion about
creativity
and
um McCarthy says how long since you
tried to do original designing and Frank
says years I can copy accurately as hell
but and then McCarthy says you know what
I think I think you've picked up the
Nazi idea that Jews can't create that
they can only imitate and sell middlemen
Frank Frank says maybe so and then
McCarthy says well try it do some
original designs or work directly on the
metal play around like a kid plays and
Frank says no and then McCarthy says you
have no faith you've completely lost
faith in yourself right too bad because
I know you could do it and he walks away
and then Frank says it is too bad but
nevertheless it is the truth I can't get
Faith or enthusiasm by willing it and
then he thinks that McCarthy is a damn
good shop foreman he has The Knack of
needling a man getting him to put his
best efforts to do his utmost in spite
of himself he's a natural leader he
almost inspired me there for a moment
and then Frank consults
the oracle
and he finds out that the Oracle the
Aging the book of changes is suggesting
to him that he ought to do as Ed
McCarthy says open my own little
business
um
so this is quite interesting and they're
going to go in together on this and
start it together right now how are they
going to get the money to be in this
this is where the blackmail comes in
and we don't actually know that it's
Frank at first but a man goes to rob her
children the Antiquities dealer or you
know Americana dealer
and suggests to him in a very long
discussion that we're not going to go
through right now because we've talked
about it elsewhere
that the
Civil War pistols that he has
are actually fakes and he's quite
correct about that they are indeed fakes
as we find out when Robert children
sends off but Frank is pretending to be
the gentleman for a an admiral whose
carrier long since sunk is supposed to
be
anchored there in the bay so Robert
childen is actually going to report him
but this is also going to kick off
an entire
let's call it
catastrophe of
reverberations going through the supply
chain so children has purchased these
fakes and then he talks to Ray Calvin
and says hey you got to take these fakes
back I can't sell them I actually lost a
really important deal and Ray Calvin
tells then when to maths and hey your
fakes aren't any damn good they're not
decent fakes and Windom Manson then is
going to think to himself
about what's going on there
and this is in chapter five there was
nothing that Wyndham Matson could think
of to say this is to Rey but he thought
to himself instantly
it's Frank and McCarthy they said they'd
do something this is it
but he couldn't figure out what they'd
done he couldn't make sense out of
Calvin's account a kind of superstitious
fright filled him those two how could
they doctor an item made last February
he had presumed they'd go to the police
or the newspapers or even the peanut
government at sac and of course he had
all those taken care of so
Frank and McCarthy are hitting him in
the one place where they know that he's
vulnerable and Rita his secretary and
mistress says tell the police
and then he thinks to himself
probably would be cheaper to offer them
2 000 or so they'd accept it that was
probably all they wanted little fellows
like that thought small to them it would
seem a lot they'd put in their new
business lose it be broke again with uh
within a month
he says no
why not blackmail's a crime and then
here's his thought process it was hard
to explain to her
he was accustomed to paying people it
was part of the overhead like the
utilities of the some was small enough
but she did have a point he mulled it
over
I'll give them two thousand now here's
where some of the other things go into
effect I'll give them two thousand but
I'll also get in touch with that guy at
the Civic Center I know that Police
Inspector I'll have them look into both
Frank and McCarthy and see if there's
anything of use for instance somebody
told me that Frank's a Jew changed his
nose and name all I got to do is notify
the German console here routine business
he'll request the Japanese authorities
for extradition they'll gas the bugger
as soon as he get a gets across the
demarcation line
and so they they talk a little bit about
you know historicity and the blackmail
and all that so what's going to happen
now well uh things are falling into
place and Frank is actually going to be
a little bit discouraged he actually
consults the Oracle they're waiting to
see if Wyndham Matson is going to come
up with a blackmail money what's the
decision about that and it seems like
the Oracle is saying no and then the
money comes and what do they do
they begin setting up the shop
McCarthy says let's do it we've got our
orders made out all we have to do is
stick them in the mail the sooner the
better and the stuff we can get locally
we'll pick up ourselves they talk
Frank's landlord into renting them the
basement of the building now it was used
for storage once the cartons were out
they could build their bench put in
wiring lights begin to mount their
Motors and belts they'd run up sketches
specifications Parts lists so they'd
already actually begun were in business
Frank Frank realized they'd even agreed
on a name Ed Frank Custom Jewelers
he says the most I can see today is
buying the wood for the bench and maybe
electrical parts and they go on now
there's a couple things that are
important in this section in chapter six
there's a discussion that happens
McCarthy says what's bothering you
and
um Frank says the money it gets me down
to finance things this way to start out
with a new Enterprise but to do it kind
of under a cloud right and this is
actually going to be quite fateful
because not only is he being looked into
because of the call to the police but
Robert Sheldon is also going to report
him as well and this will result in him
being arrested towards the end of the
the book fortunately
he's saved by the intervention of tagomi
so anyway
um what we see
Happening Here McCarthy says old Windham
Matson understands and Frank thinks yeah
I know that's why it gets me down we've
entered his world we're like him isn't
that a pleasant thought and McCarthy
says Don't Look Back look ahead to the
to the business
and Frank thinks I am looking ahead what
offerings and Libations can can I make
and to whom now we skip ahead a little
bit into
um
chapter nine they've been added for or
actually a little bit earlier than that
they've been at it now for several weeks
and creating stuff and they begin to uh
get their first batch it's time to sell
it and they take it to Robert children's
shop now Robert children is already
essentially given information about
Frank to the police
this racket that's going on and they
they know that he's Jewish so this is
going to be a real problem but now
they're going to go in there they've
made business cards they have all sorts
of other good stuff in every aspect of
their work they'd been professional
surveying their jewelry cards and
display they could see no indication of
the amateur
why should there be Frank Frank thought
we're both Pros not in jewelry making
but in shop work in general and they've
got all sorts of beautiful things cuff
bracelets made of brass copper bronze
even hot forged black Iron pendants
mostly of brass with a little silver
ornamentation earrings of silver pins of
silver or brass and he goes on and
thinks about you know what else they are
going to do semi-precious stones that
they're going to mount and perhaps
they'll even try gold and five or six
point diamonds at this point he says
they'd not yet tried to sell they'd
solved what seemed to be their basic
technical problems they had their bench
with motors Flex cable machine Arbor of
grinding and polishing wheels they had a
complete range of finishing tools
and superb Jewelers tour tools pliers
from Germany and France micrometers
Diamond drills saws tongs tweezers third
hand structures for soldering vices
polishing cloth rows of precision
equipment
they're set up legally they even have
their PSA permits nothing remained but
to sell
no retailer Frank thought as he studied
the displays can give these a tougher
inspection than we have so they go to
Robert children's store obviously
Frankfurt can't enter there because
he'll be arrested and you know children
will identify him so Ed goes in and he
brings the stuff along and he is
told yeah go ahead and lay your your
stuff out here and they go back and
forth about the terms for a bit and then
it turns out
children will only sell these pieces
on consignment now that's a problem he's
not going to purchase so there's no
money coming in and they've got to leave
their pieces there and they have to
assume any risks
so
children says I'll let you leave them
all I'll write up a tag you'll have a
record of what you left with me you
understand when merchandise is left on a
consignment basis the store doesn't
assume liability in case of theft or
damage he had a little mimeograph
released for the salesman to sign there
was no way that robber children could
lose he didn't have to pay for this
man's jewelry he had no investment in
this if any of it sold he made a profit
and if not he simply returned it all
and so Ed leaves the card and goes back
to the car and you know they're not
super happy about it but what we're
going to find is that this jewelry
particularly that which is made by Frank
Ed rightly had
faith in Frank's creative abilities
because as we discuss elsewhere
Frank's jewelry
conveys this value recognized by some of
the other characters
of woo something
primordial something new
something that arouses affects and
desires and actually has a lot of
possibility for being turned into
something that could be commercialized
although children will refuse that
now later on Frank doesn't actually know
about this in chapter 12 he begins to
get discouraged
so
um here we go
uh they'd sold nothing except for the
consignment and American artistic
handicrafts no one had taken anything
and they'd visited five retail shops and
all we're not making any money Frank
said to himself we're making more and
more jewelry and it's just piling up
around us
don't let those pieces go McCarthy said
at the welding torch and they discuss it
a bit and then Frank's thinks the hell
with the whole thing McCarthy sees him
making no move to fish up the earring
what's the matter he says and Frank says
we're pouring money in for nothing well
we can't sell what we haven't made and
Frank says we can't sell anything made
or unmade five stores drop in the bucket
but the trend Frank said it's enough to
know and
Frank says maybe it's time to start
looking for a market for scrap and
McCarthy's is fine quit and he says well
I have and McCarthy says I'll go on by
myself and then the question is how are
they going to split the stuff they can't
split a motor Frank says buy me out but
that's not a possibility either and
McCarthy proposes you know let's try
three more stores and then we'll think
about it and then
preventing this from actually you know
turning into a discussion
Frank Frank is arrested but in the
meantime
we discover that his jewelry winds up
captivating people Ed Frank is going to
or Ed Frank jewelry is going to become a
success we assume by the time that the
book ends and perhaps will even produce
a Reconciliation between Frank and his
estranged wife Juliana so this is a very
important subplot that brings together a
number of different characters Frank
Frank one of the main characters Ed
McCarthy Robert childen a number of
other characters coming in and out and
it deals with the fate of them and it
leads to the production of something
that
opens up new possibilities including for
Mr tagomi who is transported into an
alternate timeline a different history
by regarding one of the pieces that Ed
Frank jewelry is selling through Robert
childen
and was produced by Frank so a lot of
important stuff going on within this
little subplot that assumes greater and
greater importance as we go through the
novel